black ads in major newspapers marked the
mood across Israel
paid by a high-tech workers group
protesting a legislation that will
weaken the powers of the Court
the reasonableness bill was the first to
pass into law on Monday part of a highly
divisive judicial reform package pushed
by prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu and
his far-right Coalition on Ben Yehuda
Street in West Jerusalem opinions are
mixed we are deeply concerned about the
future of of the Democracy in this
country we love this country well you
need a system of checks and balances and
we don't have that in Israel since we
don't have a constitution in the 1990s
the Supreme Court
took to itself uh
extra powers that it didn't have
around the knesset and Central Tel Aviv
as anger Rose into the evening police
cracked down this headline reads it's a
black day for democracy in Israel and
here on the streets the difference
between night and day less than 24 hours
ago tens of thousands of people filled
this Square now activists say they're
exhausted but they'll continue to fight
against the changes
the bill is a bitter pill for many to
swallow doctors and medical workers
started striking Tuesday Morning
canceling non-emergency appointments
until the labor court ordered them back
to work I am wearing this black shirt
today because that's how we feel we feel
that
the bridge and the agreement between us
professionals and the government was
broken
hundreds of thousands of people have
voiced their anger on the streets for
months they say the judicial overhaul is
eroding their democracy and could put
them on a path to autocracy one
Palestinian knesset member says 1.8
million Palestinians have long faced
life without those equal rights that
kind of democracy that they are trying
to protect was not a real democracy as
long as it pushed away and alienated the
Palestinian citizens
the bill is a crushing blow to
protesters but also once exposure Rift
in Israeli society and a deepening
crisis on the streets Laura Khan Al
Jazeera West Jerusalem
foreign